PETER GIOVINE: Hi. I am Peter, and I am a
senior and English major, and Great Expectations
is my senior thesis.
KANOA MULLING: I'm playing the
characters of Joe, who's a blacksmith, lower
class, and Mr. Jaggers, who is a lawyer from
London. And it's really fun playing two completely
different characters, being lovable and detestable,
going left and right.
EVELYN GIOVINE: I'm playing Miss Havisham,
and in preparation for the play, I read the
novel Great Expectations. And there was this
really cool quote that informed my character,
and the quote was "dropped within, without,
body and soul as if under a crushing blow."
CAROLINE SLUTSKY: We see a younger version
of Estella in the Bartlett version; she's
Pip's love interest in the play and she, um,
lacks feelings and she's kind of a cold person.
JOHN FAIRCHILD: Hello, I'm John, and one of
the characters I play in Great Expectations
is Mr. Wopsle, who is a churchman/wannabe
actor. And in one scene, I have to burp, but
I don't know how to burp, so we do a little
something like this. [Jake Tempchin burps.]
Amen!
PETER: It's all as if we're seeing things
through Pip's perspective, and it's not really
what's actually happening, right; it's like
an artistic perspective, um, that makes the
world more beautiful and more magical.
CAMERON PLATT: Unexpected.
NATHALIE ELLIS-EINHORN: Crazy.
CAROLINE: Orchestral.
EVELYN: Haunting.
KANOA: Smashing.
PETER: Great.